the world's richest woman her name is
mackenzie scott and she announced her
latest donations to charity and they are
huge with a capital h
scott wrote on medium she had given more
than four billion dollars in gifts to
384 organizations over the past four
months
she has donated nearly six billion
dollars this year alone
scott who was once married to amazon's
jeff bezos said the pandemic has been
quote
a wrecking ball in the lives of
americans already struggling
some of the groups receiving her
donations include meals on wheels
goodwill and easter seals and she's not
done yet scott plans to continue
donating her fortune
as part of a giving pledge to commit a
majority of her wealth to charitable
causes
you know they say that her network is 56
billion dollars that's according to
forbes but this is the thing this is
someone who is
went through a very high profile painful
divorce
but it clearly hasn't knocked off her
game she still wants to do good
and help others at this particular time
she's smart she's compassionate and i
think
bravo bravo to her and listen she was
with jeff bezos at the very beginning
she was loading up those boxes and
packing
up going to the post office she worked
hard too so
it's good to see that she's being
acknowledged for the work that she does
too it's amazing
she's giving away billions now i know
she pledged to give away money but i
thought she'd live with it for a while
longer before she started
yeah in a way yes
bravo mackenzie scott